you know you don't care what other
people think you do things your own way
which is beautiful
all right then Lynn what's new
have you been better right been through
a lot but I still don't have a job but
tomorrow I'm gonna start looking you
share working tomorrow no I'm sorry
looking okay it's hard right now cuz it
uh what's going on um what's going on
you're still were you living though I'm
back on the streets you're staying with
a friend for a while yeah but now you're
back and no streets a Hollywood yeah I
mean I don't just stay and holy wood now
though I just like go wherever I want
so you roam around yeah just stay away
from Skid Row yeah yeah I don't come
down here good except for that that's it
for me yeah what's going on with your
the the two court cases
I got court in June early June I'm gonna
go to it's just for a fleet of like
guilty or innocent so I could plea I
guess I'm gonna plead innocent you have
a lawyer and all that public defender
for the defendant thank you these two
cases are one I think this is just for a
little one because the one with the guy
the second one with the guy the one that
I actually you know I think that's the
one that I'm gonna be pleading innocent
too I'm not sure which one it is I think
that's the one though
okay yeah and then what's going on with
the crystal meth and alcohol and stuff
like that I'm gonna be honest I'm super
thin right now because of it
but um I kicked it about a week ago
yeah crystal meth yes no I'm week ago
maybe like between yeah between four to
seven days ago okay how's that going for
you it's going pretty good I mean I know
I say I kick it a lot but there are
actually reasons as to why I do it
the alcohol is that I drink every now
and then like whenever it's around or
whatever in the bottle every day ya know
I'm not really into drinking profusely
on the streets cuz you never know what
could happen to yourself or your things
yeah absolutely so what's going on with
your with your mom have you talked to
her
no no your friends on the street oh yeah
yeah I know a lot of people you know a
lot of people like me there's a lot of
people out there yeah a lot of people
like me yeah and your video got a lot of
views are you like the people recognize
you from the videos um I know like on
the street yeah no no no Hey Oh people
are Street though you don't watch my
show no but um
they're cool with me because I got their
back in a safe way so you you helped out
some of the people on the street yeah
I've been on actually I've been buying
for the homeless and buying for the
homeless been like if somebody asked for
a cigarette if I have it I give it to
him
no questions asked if they asked for
like a dollar or two I give it to him if
I have it being super generous and it's
working out for me yeah just nice it's
nice to hear hey Dad anything bad happen
to you when you're on the street or
recently yeah on the streets no no juicy
Vic is always drawn out there yeah yeah
but it's harm it's harmless drama I mean
actually just the other night or the
other no the other day um I think it was
yesterday actually I heard this guy was
um beating on this chick that I've never
talked to you but I've seen her around
and I went up to him and um I had a
metal pole and I sat down and I talked
to him and I said a to Jeter and he's
like only like this no no I'm like I got
really angry and I yelled at him and
threatened him and I told him you ever
do that and I hit his tent with the pole
and almost broke the tent pole I think I
might have I don't know he's probably
just bent a little something wrong but I
told him if he ever does that again then
he's gonna get [ __ ] up including
crystal meth is that something you I
mean how is that gone
because they're me personally it's not
that difficult because it's not really a
need to me it's all in the mind you know
like if you think you need it then you
need it but would you consider yourself
an addict er no no no because a lot of
people smoke because they like the
feeling of smoke going into their lungs
not because of what they're smoking it's
not self-sabotage it's just like it's
considered um call me smoke and help
some people absolutely yeah yeah a
people loved it yeah yeah - on the
cigarette smoke but there's just a bit
there's actually benefits to it now
where do you see your life going from
here nowhere but up it's a nice Theory
gonna look for work that's great yeah
are you like in California yeah no
matter how bad he gets no matter how
good it good cyan't wait an almost this
coat unless this didn't go to another
state for something I need or something
that I feel I need to be there for then
I ain't going
it is rehab something you think you need
now or not that's much cuz you're
talking about that at one point I mean
I'm gonna be honest if I ever feel like
I need meth because of my weight then
I'm probably just gonna snort some
because it has a different effect than
smoking or just call me I'll buy you
pizza don't do a trick for you no I'm
just being honest that's just me
personally I mean if I feel I need it
then I'm gonna get some I'm gonna
strengthen up it's gonna make me smarter
for the moment
what is Christmas do for you kind of
wakes you up
it makes me smarter it makes me really
flirty
but I know my limits and I know how to
control myself and what I mean so your
goal is to get a job get off the street
yeah hopefully get past these the court
cases and well maybe not get off the
street but and get a job definitely
because I'm not even comfortable
sleeping in an apartment I sleep on the
floor whenever I'm in somebody's
apartment yeah what do you think that's
all about the more comfortable on the
street or on the floor an apartment then
in a bit
because I don't see why people waste
their time and their money trying to
keep a house clean and being comfortable
whenever animals don't do that and
they're perfectly fine they're natural
they're healthy they're like living off
the earth you know yeah did you have a
brother too right I have a stepbrother
yeah step right you ever talk to you no
what would you say to all the viewers
that love you and relate to you and care
about you I would tell them all just to
be happy with their lives and do what
makes them happy you know and that I
appreciate their support and everything
yeah cool Berlin great seeing you again
alright yep good luck with the finding
work and everything else okay
you